cette guerre en ukraine est leur bas
aussi les cartes sur les grandes
alliances diplomatiques lax chine russie
et il renforcer ou affaiblis comment
l'europe peut-elle jouer sa carte avec
pékin on va en débattre dans une minute
juste après avoir posé les enjeux grâce
à sandra
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
la chine maintient une position
officielle de neutralité
une neutralité de façade qui cache un
soutien implicite à moscou le régime
chinois n'a jamais condamné
l'intervention russe refuse de parler
d'invasion en ukraine et s'est même
prononcé contre une exclusion de la
russie du prochain sommet du g20 le chef
de l'otan appellent la chine à assumer
ses responsabilités
face
à la chine a fourni à la russie un
soutien politique notamment en diffusant
des mensonges flagrants en faisant de la
désinformation et les alliés craignent
que la chine ne fournissent un soutien
matériel à l'invasion russe pour pékin
les états unis et l'otan sont
responsables de la guerre en ukraine
nous espérons que les états unis et
l'otan pourront réfléchir à leur rôle
dans la crise ukrainienne assumer les
responsabilités qui leur incombent et
prendre des mesures pratiques pour
améliorer la situation et résoudre le
problème afin d'apporter une solution
rapide au conflit en ukraine la chine
s'oppose publiquement aux sanctions
économiques imposées par les états unis
et l'europe et considère que les
échanges commerciaux doivent continuer
la deuxième puissance mondiale
devra-t-elle ajuster sa position pour
cette spécialiste c'est peu probable
parce que la chine considère que la
russie est un partenaire stratégique
dans ce qu'elle considère être
l'avènement d'un monde post excellente
et que la chine pourrait mettre en place
différents moyens de contournement des
sanctions en passant par des banques de
plus petite taille pour cette année ces
transactions ont aussi en essayant de
développer des monnaies digital ce
qu'elle a déjà commencé à faire avec le
hand et chez talent pour contourner les
sanctions américaines
un jeu d'équilibriste pour la chine qui
connaît actuellement un ralentissement
de sa croissance économique
le front diplomatique c'est ce qui va
nous passionner dans ce débat et je vous
présente mes invités sylvie bermann
bonsoir bis rue aussi ambassadrice de
france en chine au royaume uni et en
russie donc comme on va comparer parler
de lax moscou pékin voilà vous êtes
particulièrement bien placé pour nous en
parler présidente du groupe de travail
union européenne-chine de l'institut
jacques delors j'accueille également
elvire fabry bonsoir bienvenue
chercheuse senior à l'institut jacques
delors toujours pour lequel vous avez
travaillé ensemble à ce rapport
construire l'autonomie stratégique de
l'europe face à la chine et ce sera
vraiment l'un des thèmes de notre débat
en toi demande à ce bon soin au soir du
chargé de recherche à la fondation pour
la recherche stratégique et vous êtes
spécialiste de la chine laetitia cru pas
unitariste politique toujours à mes
côtés on va longuement parlé de cet axe
chine russie mais d'abord quand même un
mode de ces négociations qui se sont
déroulées aujourd'hui en turquie et on
écoute le président turc recep tayyip
erdogan
il sera dans l'intérêt de tous de
parvenir à un cessez-le-feu et à la paix
le plus rapidement possible
nous pensons que nous sommes maintenant
entrés dans une phase où les pourparlers
doivent donner des résultats tangibles
en tant que membre de la délégation
vous avez assumé une responsabilité
historique
le monde entier attend de bonnes
nouvelles de votre part effectivement
dans cette journée il ya eu comme ça
égrainé un certain nombre de potentiels
bonne nouvelle l'hypothèse d'une
rencontre entre ce qui est et poutine
annoncent par les russes d'un d'un
retrait d'une partie de leurs troupes en
tout cas une réduction de leur offensive
à la formule que je recherchais sylvie
bernard herrmann est ce qu on assiste
depuis 48 heures à un tournant ou est-ce
que c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire
non je crois que c'est la première fois
qu'il se passe quelque chose sur le plan
diplomatique parce qu'il y avait eu des
pourparlers à la frontière entre la
pologne et la biélorussie mais les
négociateurs eux-même avait dit qu'il ne
progressait que sur des questions
secondaires il y avait une rencontre de
19 minutes entre les ministres des
affaires étrangères russe et ukrainien à
lire et à peu près 15 jours et là c'est
la première fois qu'il y à des
discussions de substances et des
possibilités d'accord sur la neutralité
de l'ukraine à condition qu'il y ait des
garanties
des puissances internationales membres
du conseil de sécurité et quelques pays
voisins qui ont joué un rôle dont la
turquie précisément israël la pologne et
l'allemagne
et puis également des esquisses de
solution sur le dombass la crimée enfin
pas vraiment des solutions mais il
accepte d'en parler et en réalité de ne
pas prendre de décisions sur ces régions
occupées en discutant de la neutralité
parce qu'autrement la difficulté c'était
de savoir quelles étaient les frontières
de de l'ukraine donc il ya quand même
quelque chose qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui plus effectivement la
décision de
réduire les attaques contre contre kiev
et de se concentrer sur le donbass qui
était
le but de guerre d'une certaine manière
de vladimir poutine quand il a annoncé
le 21 février le la guerre et lire
sabrié est ce que c'est parce que les
lignes ont bougé
unitaire que l'on peut
imaginez que
ça bouge aussi en termes diplomatiques
est ce que c'est un constat de faiblesse
je mets évidemment de la prudence
derrière ces termes là de la part de
l'animal poutine ce qui est en train de
se passer écoutez ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on voit que le dialogue est
engagé et c'est ce maintien oui on sent
quand même qu'on est dans une phase un
petit peu de leur proportion un petit
peu les choses à la fois on voit la
position de la russie sur son
positionnement militaire sur la menace
nucléaire
oulala du mercou tina a repris un
discours un peu plus un peu plus prudent
de les deux lignes rouges donc on est
entrain peut-être de passer il faut le
dire on avance avec prudence mais
peut-être à une deuxième phase de la
confrontation oui et puis avec des
réactions de diplomatie américaine ou
britannique qui justement disent
attention voilà ne soyons pas trop trop
optimiste mais cette rencontre poutine
zelensky non on peut commencer à
imaginer
son éventualité
alors si un accord est potentiellement
sur le point d'être signé je pense qu'il
n'y a pas de raisons pour les deux
dirigeants de se rencontrer au cours des
négociations plus tôt pour mettre un
terme à ces négociations et aboutir si
il y avait un accord sur cet accord je
pense que ce qui est très important ce
site souligné le rôle important que joue
la turquie on voit une turquie membre de
l'otan a lié de fait des états unis et
des européens malgré les tensions
récentes par exemple avec la france qui
joue un rôle extrêmement important
extrêmement positif et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut souligner dans les
ambitions notamment turquie dans une
grande puissance régionale qui sont des
ambitions qui sont anciennes et là
vraiment la turquie tire son épingle du
jeu en se rapprochant entre guillemets à
la fois des européens à la fois des
russes et ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut aussi souligner erdogan
poutine xi jin pyng est ce que est ce
que vous les mettez est ce qu'on parle
là d'un axe des autocrates en quelque
sorte si lieberman ou est-ce que je vais
beaucoup trop est ce que c'est c'est
trop caricatural ont en tout cas ce sont
deux dirigeants qui ont des rêves dans
pire je crois qu'on peut les qualifier
d'autocrates
erdogan et on analyse bien sûr non mais
ces trois pays il a effectivement ont la
nostalgie d'une gloire passée qu'ils
veulent retrouver et les relations en
tout cas entre la russie et la turquie
sont assez intéressante parce qu'ils
sont en conflit sur différents terrains
comme en syrie ou en libye est en
réalité à la fin ils s'entendent
toujours et la r douanes voulait jouer
depuis longtemps un rôle sur ce conflit
parce qu'il avait même proposé
d'accueillir les négociations sur la
mise en oeuvre des accords de minsk qui
ne pouvait plus se tenir naturellement
en biélorussie et il a conservé ses
liens forts avec poutine il a fourni des
armes comme les drones bayraktar qui
sont très très efficace et en même temps
il n'a pas sanctionné la russie ce qui
lui permet d'ailleurs d'accueillir tous
les négociateurs russes qui sont
ailleurs sous sanction nos confrères de
l'express titrait la semaine dernière
sur un axe chine russie ceux qui veulent
défaire l'occident voilà ce que le tea
qui avait été choisi par l'express et
est-ce qu'il ya une sorte de pacte
sino-russe
le pacte d'une certaine façon il a déjà
été mis sur la table début février au
moment de l'ouverture des jeux
olympiques
de pékin et on voit que c'était un pacte
non seulement économique mais
idéologique une mais un alignement sur
une même vision de qui aller assez loin
même de fonctionnement alternatif de la
démocratie il n'ya pas que le modèle
occidental de démocratie a aussi entre
guillemets la démocratie à la chinoise à
la russe et il libéra la libérale
exactement et avec ce même
rêve dans pire comme l'évoquait sylvie
sylvie bermann il est la volonté
finalement de pouvoir présenter un ordre
international aussi une vision de
l'organisation internationale
alternative plus de représentation des
pays émergents dans les organisations
internationales
on voit qu'il ya à la fois une volonté
structurelles de long terme de rapport
d'intérêt disons d'intérêt mutuel si ce
n'est un alignement complet d'intérêt
mutuel et regardent dans la même
direction et la volonté de pouvoir
séduire d'autres pays tiers et les de
faire un peu contrepoids à ce monde
occidental qui a organisé à la fois
l'économie et les institutions
internationales toutes ces dernières
décennies si on fait un peu d'histoire
en train de mandat soit rappelé que ces
deux pays la chine a aussi on pas ont
pas toujours été amis c'est le moins
qu'on puisse bien sûr pour faire très
court à partir de 1960 et jusqu'à la fin
de la guerre froide la russie enfin
l'urss à l'époque est l'ennemi de la
chine et c'est véritablement
l'effondrement de l'urss qui fait que
l'urss et demi va devenir une russie
partenaires on a ce rapprochement
d'aujourd'hui qui en réalité date des
années 90 les premiers grands accords
énergétiques par exemple date du milieu
des années 90 les premières grandes
déclarations matière de stabilité
stratégique par exemple date de la fin
des années 90 et puis c'est ensuite la
volonté d'avoir une coordination avec
l'inde puis élargie au brésil quand on a
la formation des briques puis à
l'afrique du sud avec les brics donc on
a une coordination qui est ancienne qui
évidemment s'est renforcé à partir de
2014 suite aux sanctions occidentales
sur la russie suite à l'invasion de la
crimée et qui partent notamment ces
dernières années d'un constat qui est
identique à pékin comme à moscou c'est
que la russie n'est pas une menace pour
le régime politique chinois et vice
versa par contre les etats-unis et plus
largement les occidentaux sont
considérés comme une menace qu'elle soit
à juste titre ou non et donc on a cette
sorte de paranoïa en termes de sécurité
politique fasse ce qui est perçu souvent
comme une volonté américaine et plus
largement occidentale de renverser et
gym avec toute la rhétorique un des
révolutions de couleurs que ce soit en
asie centrale que ce soit en ukraine que
ce soit même à hong kong et c'est
notamment cette notion de sécurité
politique aujourd'hui qui rapproche la
russie et la chine et qui fait que la
chine n'est pas aujourd'hui un médiateur
dans cette guerre comme malheureusement
en tout cas comme certains l'espéraient
c'était le cas par exemple du haut
représentant joseph bourrel oui on
l'évoquera tout à l'heure mais laëtitia
vous êtes intéressé à la propagande
voilà ces deux pays ont des similitudes
on l'a on l'a bien compris ce que la
propagande chinoise va dans le sens de
la propagande russe oui et d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites ils
considèrent l'occident est les
etats-unis l'europe comme une menace
aussi thomas pour leurs opinions
publiques parce que leur pouvoir est
assis quand même sur un impact social il
ya quand même des millions de russes et
des millions de chinois il n'ya pas
qu'eux on a toujours tendance à
personnaliser comme ça le pouvoir il ya
les opinions publiques et oui il existe
une coopération dans la désinformation
puisque je vous conseille un article à
ce sujet du monde qui est intitulé en
chine les partisans de l'ukraine ne s'en
laisse pas compter et en fait le
correspondant à pékin frédérick lemaître
explique comment les médias d'état russe
et chinois coopère par exemple depuis
2013 ils ont passé des accords
d'échangés de contenus et donc quand sur
un réseau social chinois à vous taper
ukraine surgit directement un article
par exemple de spoutnik vous savez cette
agence qui est à la solde du pouvoir
russe et il y a des accords dans la
désinformation des accords qui sont
vraiment écrit qui sont passés entre les
deux états il y a bien sûr en chine
comme en russie la censure sur les
réseaux sociaux dès qu'un poste ou un
article pro ukraine apparaît mais il y
un mais et c'est comme ça aussi que je
vois les réseaux sociaux et internet il
ya tout le côté positif c'est à dire
qu'on ne peut pas complètement fermé ses
tuyaux on ne peut pas complètement les
contrôler et en chine les internautes
commencent à s'emparer du débat par
exemple même à la télévision le mot
guerre apparaît depuis la mi mars donc
vous voyez que les opinions alors c'est
peut coupler langue chez nous mais sa
tante à bouger et il y a pour nous pour
une a sion la vidéo de daniel schorn
égard je ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu
cette vidéo dizaine de jours oui il l'a
postée sur instagram il s'adresse aux
russes et s'est traduit en chinois je
dis ça parce qu'en fait ça a mis un peu
plus de temps à arriver en chine et a
tourné et là cette vidéo commence à
devenir virale on va regarder un tout
petit extrait
vous entendez il dit qu' il veut leur
dire quelque chose et leur montrer ce
qu'ils auraient caché et c'est vrai
qu'il a une bonne attitude une bonne
communication était très habitué à
marchesa guerre de hollywood jusqu'à la
californie il est passé de la douane
chant d'artistes à celui de la politique
et donc ils manipulent la communication
comme personne il commence à dire aux
russes je suis avec vous il s'adresse à
ses fans à ses millions de fans je vous
soutiens je reconnais votre grandeur je
vous aime c'est carrément une
déclaration est ensuite voilà ce qu'on
vous cache est ce qu'on ne montre pas
les bombardements par exemple la
maternité de mario paul il s'adresse aux
soldats russes en disant on vous dit
d'aller tuer des nazis c'est de la
propagande et donc oui la chemise un il
donne même à la fin comme un conseil
menaçable à nîmes hier poutine et cette
vidéo commence je vous le dis à devenir
virale en chine c'est vraiment
intéressant
sylvie bermann vous qui avait été en
poste dans les deux dans les deux
capitales la machine de propagande est
ce qu'elle est aussi efficace d'un côté
l'autre ce qu'on se pose toujours la
question de ce que ça de ce que voient
les russes aujourd'hui alors il y avait
une grande différence à l'époque où
j'étais parce qu'en fait il y avait
assez peu il y avait une censure totale
en chine qui s'était renforcée au fil
des années surtout depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de sit-in ping avant il y avait
des débats sur le twitter chinois weibo
tout ça a disparu en revanche en russie
même si les télévisions et les
la majorité de la presse a été contrôlée
par par le pouvoir vous pouviez voir
n'importe quel reportage sur la russie
critique sur l'a10 vers poutine aussi
avait aucune censure de ce point de vue
là et maintenant elle est totale elle
est totale puisque la plupart des
journaux étrangers sont plus ou moins
soumis aux mêmes lois que les russes
les licences des journalistes sont
octroyés tous les trois mois seulement
donc ça permet de maintenir ce contrôle
mais il ya eu effectivement des
influences réciproques ils ont discuté
ils ont discuté du contrôle de
l'internet
au fil du renforcement de leurs
relations alors c'est vrai qui a
commencé bon 2013 2014 mais qui sert en
fait renforcée pendant les années 30 et
quand j'ai quitté la russie un des
spécialistes de l'asie m'a dit on
pourrait ériger une statue à donald
trump pour notre amitié retrouvée et en
disant depuis catherine la grande on n'a
jamais eu d'aussi bonnes relations entre
les deux pays entre la russie et la
chine à rome grâce à train mais grâce à
cette perception de l'étranger c'est à
dire le principe c'est l'ennemi de mon
ennemi est mon ami et comme ils
perçoivent eux l'hostilité américaine et
l'hostilité de l'otan parce que si les
russes si les chinois aujourd'hui
soutiennent le narratif russe c'est
aussi parce que le temps a prétendu
s'occuper de la chine est donc pas du
tout envie donc il ya ce rapprochement
qui est lié à ce qu'ils perçoivent comme
une volonté des occidentaux est de plus
en plus collectivement d'ailleurs c'est
à dire états unis et europe alors
qu'avant les chinois faisaient la
différence entre entre les deux presque
de changer leur régime ou leur système
et quand joe biden en pologne fini son
discours en disant pour l'amour de dieu
il faut que
la dîmière poutine de parts ça alimente
ce discours sur les changements de
régime vers fabry vous parler de
neutralité ans venu pour la chine depuis
le début de ce conflit en ukraine
l'invasion russe l'enjeu pour itunes
ping c'est quoi ces de s'isoler ou non
du bloc occidental
cc c'est un peu ça
l'enjeu pour ces jean king c'est de
suivre ses propres intérêts et donc de
limiter il ne peut pas aller condamné la
russie il essaye de se maintenir sur
cette ligne de crête en ménageant ses
intérêts de court terme de moyen terme
de long terme long terme on l'a bien
compris c'est de pouvoir renforcer les
liens économiques mettre la main sur les
approvisionnements en gaz lorsque les
infrastructures le 'pipeline' le
permettrons mais à plus court terme et
déjà
pouvoir aussi récupérer le le blé russe
alors que la chine est plus en plus
dépendante d'importations en matière
agricole
et d
aider un minimum économiquement tant
qu'elle peut par des le biais de petites
banques plus discrètement c'est une
c'est une possibilité ne pas s'exposer
aux sanctions américaines puisque c'est
les américains surtout la possibilité
d'utiliser leur extraterritorialité pour
éventuellement poursuivre les poursuivre
lisez les entreprises chinoises qui
pourraient transmettre des technologies
pour soutenir justement tout le tout
l'équipement militaire russe qui
commence déjà à avoir des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en pièces détachées
là ça devient beaucoup plus compliqué à
un moment où l'économie chinoise est en
ont pas en berne mais connaît déjà des
difficultés un pub qui pour l'année 2022
s'annonce très limite à 5 5% dans le
meilleur des scénarios une crise dans le
secteur immobilier qui est très
problèmes qui continuent à être très
problématique beaucoup de turbulences
sur les marchés financiers chinois
malgré le soutien de l'état un pic de co
vide on voit bien que ce n'est pas un
bon moment pour la chine et que ce
dossier russe il est aussi relativement
toxique pour le l'évolution de
l'économie chinoise est alors sur sur la
question du rôle de de la chine dans
dans ce conflit sa place diplomatique je
vous propose d'écouter le président
américain joe biden s'était jeudi
dernier
lors du sommet de l'otan il parle
justement de son homologue chinois
la chine comprend que son avenir
économique est beaucoup plus étroitement
lié à l'occident qu'à la russie
est donc j'espère que le président
chinois
ne s'engagera pas
ce qu'est ce qui se joue parlait de deux
lignes rouges et un certain nombre lors
de cette journée intense là denis plots
massy à à bruxelles où il ya eu trois
sommets en une journée qu'est ce qui
s'est joué un certain nombre de
marqueurs comme ça qu'on était présente
et a lâché en disant attention voilà ce
qu'il faut surtout pas faire alors je
sais pas si imposer des lignes rôle de
la chine et ce qui marche il faut bien
comprendre que l'intérêt de la chine
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas forcément de
soutenir militairement la russie
apparemment ça irait à l'encontre de la
politique étrangère et de sécurité
chinoises depuis plusieurs décennies
deuxièmement est-ce que ça permettrait
véritablement malgré le coût politique
énorme de changer la donne sur le
terrain rien ne le garantit et puis la
chine évidemment s'exposerait à
potentiellement des sanctions mais en
tout cas des critiques extrêmement forte
du côté des européens mais aussi les
américains donc quand les américains
pendant un temps de 10 ha ils font
peut-être un peu plus de politique
intérieure que de
devenir pas de réalité ou de risquerez
ça que de la politique intérieure c'est
aussi des messages envoyés aux européens
pour que les européens perçoivent la
chine potentiellement encore comme un
adversaire alignés sûr la chine
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas alignée sur
alors il ya des intérêts convergents et
vous l'avez parfaitement rappelé
l'objectif de la chine ce n'est pas de
reprendre bêtement la propagande russe
c'est de reprendre les éléments de
langage russe qui vont dans le sens des
éléments de langage que la chine met
toujours en avant la question du
changement de régime la question de ces
laboratoires biologique que les
américains auraient en ukraine c'est une
vieille rumeur en chine qui circulent
notamment depuis mars 2020 et le début
de la pandémie pour sous-entendre que le
virus de la commune 19 viendrait des
états unis soit de fort detrick dans le
maryland aux états unis soit peut-être
de l'ukraine ce sont des vieilles
rumeurs qui sont reprises aujourd'hui
mais là où il faut faire attention c'est
qu'il ya une asymétrie total dans la
façon dont on couvre la guerre en
ukraine en europe et la façon dont tout
cela couvre en chine c'est une chose de
trouver des articles en chine sur la
guerre en ukraine même si encore une
fois le terme de guerre n'est pas
utilisé explicitement pour l'instant on
parle de guerre quand xinping notamment
fait la différence entre la guerre que
met en avant notamment les états unis ou
potentiellement le terme de guerre en
général et la paix que cherche la chine
le terme qui continue d'être utilisé
c'est celui de crise ou de tension en
ukraine mais surtout quand vous lisez le
quotidien du peuple et la version papier
qui est la plus importante puisque c'est
les choix éditoriaux on voit à travers
la place qui donne l ukraine on part
quasiment pas d'ukraine vous n'avez
quasiment aucun éditorial sur le kremlin
avait eu un et une dizaine de jours qui
critiquait la politique américaine et à
côté sur la même page un article
beaucoup plus l'on parle de quelque
chose qui n'avait rien à voir mais sur
le même thème la critique des états unis
c'était la critique de la situation dans
les prisons américaines
la violation des droits de l'homme dans
les prisons américaines et donc il faut
bien comprendre que on a souvent un
biais en pensant que la chine est obsédé
par ce qui se passe en ukraine alors je
pense qu évidemment les diplomates
chinois se pose énormément de questions
et que le moment est extrêmement
important mais dans la presse chinoise
ce dont on parle c'est avant tout du
système de gestion et de la façon dont
les autorités politiques gèrent le pire
en ce moment on m'avait ce qu'on appelle
les doubles session il y a trois
semaines c'est les deux sessions
parlementaires dans lesquels on à
l'adoption de lois ça c'était le sujet
omniprésent dans les médias
aujourd'hui c'est notamment la lutte
contre la pandémie et ça c'est une
inquiétude y compris sur le plan
économique bien plus importante que les
conséquences de l'ukraine avec juste un
point pour compléter ce que disait
parfaitement elvire une inquiétude
chinois sur ses importations notamment
de certaines matières premières
agricoles et notamment le maïs venant
d'ukraine pas tant le blé mais le maïs
pour le quoi et ukraine puisque 30% des
importations chinoises de maïs via
l'ukraine non pas pour une utilisation
humaine entre guillemets mais pour
alimenter le bétail et ça c'est
extrêmement important pour la chine a
justement c'est le thème de la chronique
de fanny conquis tout de suite fanni qui
doit être juste là en coulisses et qui
peut nous rejoindre
re bonsoir serait dit donc on détaille
vous avez creusé les relations
commerciales effectivement entre la
chine et la russie n'ont effectivement à
la chine est le premier partenaire
commercial de la russie mais l'envers ce
n'est pas vrai un la russie est en effet
dix huitième partenaire commercial de
pékin loin derrière l'union européenne
et les etats unis alors dans le détail
un regard des ces chiffres l'an dernier
la chine a réalisé près de 81 milliards
de dollars d'achats en russie c'est 3%
de ses importations et du côté des
exports ses ventes à moscou représenté
67 milliards environ 2 dollars soit 2 %
seulement du total des exportations
chinoises cependant la russie occupe une
place majeure dans certains secteurs
dans l'énergie par exemple a réussi le
deuxième fournisseur de pétrole de la
chine derrière l'arabie saoudite vous
allez le voir et puis le gaz naturel
russe représente 5% de la consommation
chinoise mais cela ne cesse d'augmenter
un récemment la chine a conclu un accord
pour l'achat de 10 milliards de mètres
cubes de gaz supplémentaires
supplémentaires par an provenant de
l'extrême orient russe et par ailleurs
les deux pays développent également des
projets de gazoducs ensemble premier
étant entré en service en 2019 mais la
chine a aussi des intérêts stratégiques
en ukraine et oui vous en parliez à
l'instant à l'ukraine alimente la chine
en matières premières notamment en
minerai de fer et puis par ailleurs en
termes d'approvisionnement alimentaire
la chine a besoin de lui rennes en 2020
par exemple l'ukraine a exporté 7
millions de tonnes de céréales vers la
chine pour un montant proche de 2
milliards d'euros et puis enfin il faut
noter aussi à l'impact de cette guerre
en ukraine sur ce qu'on appelle les
nouvelles routes de la soie ces
infrastructures ferroviaires qui relie
la chine à l'europe et au delà des
conséquences sur les infrastructures
elle-même ce sont surtout les sanctions
économiques décidées par l'europe contre
la russie qui pourrait impacter ses
échanges en termes de fret merci famille
elvire fabry sk des entreprises
chinoises qui on avait un débat hier sur
ce plateau sur les entreprises
françaises comme comment doivent-elles
réagir face aux injonctions se retirer
rester en russie ou pas essayer des
entreprises chinoises qui ont décidé de
suspendre ou d'arrêter leurs activités
en russie aujourd'hui ou est ce que
c'est un non débat puisque je rebondis
sur ce que disait antoine en asie si les
il ya une injonction enfin on parle de
renault 2 du groupe mulliez ce tous les
jours manifestement en chine ça a l'air
d'être d'être central est ce que pour
autant les entreprises qui anticipe sur
une sanction d'une clientèle mondiale
qui pourrait leur dire vous vous êtes
toujours en aussi il ya certaines
banques c'est au lait dans le conflit
qui ont commencé à interrompre les prêts
les systèmes de financement
pour les échanges commerciaux il ya en
revanche un appel du gouvernement auprès
des entreprises chinoises à occuper le
terrain
laisser éventuellement par les
occidentaux et là c'est un appel auprès
des entreprises privées et qui pour le
moment rencontre à une réponse
relativement prudente parce que parce
que justement ces entreprises privées
attendent plutôt de voir ce que quel va
être le comportement des grandes
entreprises publiques chinoises et c'est
vrai que c'est pas de temps un an
j'aurais de réputation comme pour les
pour les entreprises occidentales mais
c'est plutôt la crainte de se faire
passer les doigts par les
sanctions américaines encore une fois
partout le les enjeux notamment dans le
domaine technologique tous les biens
intermédiaires qui pourraient être
exportés vers la russie oui une
entreprise chinoise qui appelle sinopec
qui devait investir 500 millions de
dollars dans une nouvelle usine gazières
en russie et qui a annoncé que ces
investissements étaient suspendues
jusqu'à nouvel ordre on peut imaginer
que c'est effectivement lié aux menaces
de sanctions américaines mais sylvie
hébert nation vin un peu plus loin ce
qui se joue là
mais pas seulement avec cette guerre en
ukraine c'est à dire que après la
pandémie on a tous employer le terme de
relocalisation de volonté européenne de
me construire son indépendance tout ça
ça ça fracturé une partie des des
objectifs de de la chine potentiellement
pour pour les années à venir je pense
qu'il ya d'une certaine manière une
fracturation du fracture du monde parce
que on a d'un côté l'occident
de l'autre côté vous avez ces empires
russe chinois la démocratie contre
l'autocratie d'une certaine manière mais
on parle pas du reste du monde vous
savez on parle souvent aux nations unies
de waste and there is under est
effectivement bon l'ouest et leurs aises
et on s'aperçoit d'ailleurs que les pays
alors les pays qui ont été cités tout à
l'heure par antoine bande à mon l'un
d'eux là et puis il ya également le
pakistan le brésil
n'ont pas voulu se prononcer contre la
russie aux nations unies il ya quand
même trente cinq pays qui se sont
abstenus
dans les 35 pays il ya cinq ya quinze
pays africains où 17 17 pays africains
c'est quand même très très important et
je pense que on devra tenir compte de
cela à l'avenir vous aurez ce cd est ce
que vous lâchez sera dévoilée ce serait
une nouvelle
nouvelle guerre froide nouvelles
frontières entre démocratie autocratie
et que le reste du monde devra s'aligner
soit sur l'un des camps soit sur l'autre
alors je pense qu'ils ne voudront pas
s'aligner justement eux aussi voudront
leur autonomie stratégique qui considère
que ce n'est pas aux occidentaux ou même
aux chinois ou aux russes de de dicter
leurs positions quand il ya eu le sommet
russie afrique en octobre 2019 c'était
la première fois c'est sûr le modèle
chinois qui lui-même s'était inspiré du
modèle français et nous ont dit mais en
nous si d'autres pays où d'autres
puissances s'intéresse à nous tant mieux
donc je pense qu'ils vont vouloir jouer
leur propre partition mais je pense que
nous aurons intérêt dans l'après-guerre
à tenir compte de cela parce qu'on parle
toujours de communauté internationale
ban a été la communauté internationale
elle se réduit à l'occident mais je
repose la question peut-être y passerait
bien formulé non mais parce que le la
puissance économique chinoise elle
repose quand même sur la mondialisation
c'est une évidence de vieillir ça donc
ce mouvement un peu de de recentrage
peut-être continent par continent un
peut nuire à la puissance est un peu
trop simple encore ce nom parce que je
pense que de toute façon la chine va
continuer à exporter mais elle a défini
ce qu'elle appelle la circulation dual
c'est à dire à la fois on poursuit les
exportations mais la croissance chinoise
ne peut pas ne doit pas être uniquement
conduite par les des exportations et
donc il y a une importance de la
consommation intérieure et quand on
considère que c'est quand même un pays
d'un milliard quatre cent mille
habitants ils ont de la marge ce qui est
d'ailleurs l inverse le problème que
rencontre la russie qui est en train de
conduire de se dépeupler 145 145
millions d'habitants et là il ya des
départs d'ailleurs est un peu une fuite
de cerveaux via helsinki ou la turquie
ce qui est aussi un des effets de cette
guerre mais mais mais donc tous les pays
veulent relocaliser d'une certaine
manière et être autonome oui alors il
nous reste à les quelques minutes un peu
moins de sept minutes j'aurais quand
même con qu'on fasse un focus pour
terminer sur sur l'europe et la chine
c'était le construire l'autonomie
stratégique de l'europe face à la chine
ce titre de ce rapport sur lequel vous
avez travaillé d'une et l'autre pour
pour l'institut jacques delors là aussi
la guerre en ukraine est ce que vous
direz qu elle a rebattu les cartes par
rapport à ce que vous aviez pré pré
écrit travailler pour ce rapport et ce
qui se passe depuis depuis un mois s'est
accentuée c'est un rapport auquel
d'ailleurs antoine bauza également à
redon
le wiz à rabat les cartes way sa robe à
l'école complément oui parce que le ce
découplage qu'évoquait sylvie berman qui
était déjà et on s'est amorcée par les
états unis mais auquel la chine
répondait elle même par ses on va dire
des mesures miroir un peu adopté en
réplique des des initiatives prises par
les états unis en termes
d'extraterritorialité nettoyer les
structures les infrastructures notamment
dans le domaine de la formation des
technologies étrangères
ce découplage il est fortement accéléré
et la position européenne jusqu'ici
c'était d'essayer de trouver un peu une
troisième voie en fonction de ses
propres intérêts et c'était l'objet de
notre rapport c'était d'abord de partir
des intérêts secteur par secteur des
intérêts européens et ensuite voir
quelle était la réponse à adopter on
voit bien que la dans la réponse aux
conflits ukrainiens et les mesures de
court terme sortir du gaz russe
l'enjeu militaire quelle impulsion ça
peut donner à plus de coordination entre
les européens mais également nous
tourner vers plus d'achats militaires
certains états membres en tout cas du
côté transatlantique il ya des liens qui
sont dans la dans le conflit qui sont
resserrés au niveau transatlantique et
pour sécuriser aussi les
approvisionnements en matières premières
terra
enfin toute une série de toute une série
de domaines de dépendance stratégique et
en même temps l'union européenne et ce
qu'elle a intérêt à elle véritablement
poussé vers la rivalité systémique et ce
en voyant cet espace de partenariat
coopération concurrence avec un marché
chinois dont personne ne peut se passer
à court terme les chinois ne peuvent pas
se passer aujourd'hui du marché européen
et américain mais nous mêmes il est
difficile de se passer de se passer de
ce marché chinois qui est de plus en
plus
compétitifs en matière technologique
normative enfin c'est il faut qu'on il
faut engager une compétition équitable
et c'est pour ça que les européens ont
mis sur la table toute une série
d'instruments de défense autonome
commercial et sont de plus en plus
offensif sur cet agenda de level playing
field le concurrence équitable mais il
va falloir dans un progressivement dans
un deuxième temps voir comment on a
juste notre stratégie parce qu'on a le
conflit aujourd'hui est prégnant c'est
la priorité et on en est pas en est loin
d'en être sorti mais le défi structurel
des décennies à venir ça reste la
question chinoise alors antoine bon
d'asile il ya une opportunité à saisir
avec avec cette guerre en ukraine pour
la diplomatie européenne pour inventer
cette troisième voie dans ton dont on
parlait sur une troisième voie c'est
compliqué puisque dans les attributs de
puissance l'union européenne n'a
malheureusement ou heureusement diront
certains pas des attributs de puissance
qui sont indispensables pour pouvoir
peser véritablement notamment dans le
plan ni terre sur les questions
économiques sur les questions de normes
sur les questions environnementales
l'union européenne a évidemment
énormément de choses à faire ce qui est
très important on parle souvent d'un dos
pacifique de ce que pourrait faire
l'union européenne en eau de pacifique
je pense qu'il faut vraiment comprendre
qu on a un rôle à jouer qu'il faut avoir
un agenda positif qu'il ne faut pas
toujours qu'ils soient en réaction à ce
que fait la chine et qui a des grands
enjeux globaux dans lesquelles la chine
est un partenaire et dans lequel la
chine n'est pas forcément un adversaire
quand on parle aujourd'hui de l'inde au
pacifique c'est 50% des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre dans le monde ces sept
des dix plus grands consommateurs
de charbon ce sont des enjeux en matière
de catastrophes naturelles et de mesures
de prévention de réponse à ces
catastrophes naturelles qui sont
considérables et dans ce cadre là les
européens ils ont un rôle à jouer en
matière encore une fois économiques
environnementales et avec un agenda qui
soit positif et y compris pour donner
des alternatives à ces pays justement
pour ne pas les laisser être obligés de
choisir entre soi des financements
américains soient des financements
chinois essaient de fait déjà le cas
l'union européenne c'est le premier
investisseur dans la région l'union
européenne c'est le premier fournisseur
d'aidé publique au développement
vis-à-vis des pays de la région prennent
des européens c'est souvent qu'il ya un
manque de cohérence un manque de
coordination et très certainement un
manque de communication sur ce que font
déjà les européens sylvie bermann on l'a
évoqué mais très rapidement j'aimerais
vous entendre là dessus pourquoi la la
chine ne joue pas un rôle plus important
dans ce qui a été le point de départ de
notre débat le ballet diplomatique la
recherche de solutions pour sortir de
ces drones
d'abord je crois que la chute a pas
tellement l'habitude de jouer un rôle de
médiateur elle l'a fait à titre
exceptionnel entre le
soudan et le sud soudan mais en dehors
de ça est là c'est pas tellement son
rôle elle ne prend pas tellement
d'initiative sur la scène internationale
la plupart du temps elle dit il faut que
les deux parties aboutissent ou là la
paix ou fassent preuve de retenue et par
ailleurs elle est un petit peu lié à la
demi-heure pour teen quand même parce
que je crois que le pacte général c'est
que il n'y aura jamais d'atteinte aux
intérêts de l'un ou de
ou de l'autre alors ils peuvent diverger
sur certaines choses il peut s'abstenir
au lieu de soutenir la russie ce qui est
bien compris mais je pense que la russie
que la chine pardon qui finalement n'a
de rôle important sur la scène
diplomatique internationale que depuis
assez récemment c'est une puissance
géoéconomique avant d'être une puissance
géopolitique donc elle n'a pas encore
cette pratique delà de la médiation ça
pourrait changer ça
met tout dans un scénario où le géant
économique
ce père col de plus en plus avec la
géopolitique où on a un affrontement
plus fort avec des mesures de coercition
économie qui deviennent plus agressive
si on veut si je veux continuer c'est
une grande puissance économique il faut
que je
je prenne un peu plus de risques
diplomatiques c'est peut-être ça peut
être ça oui et puis ça nous renvoie à
une question qu'on n'a pas encore abordé
la question de taiwan ah oui
évidemment je pourrais peut-être que
c'est pas la une des journaux chinois
mais c'est évident que les diplomates
chinois étudient ce qui se passe et
notamment les sanctions occidentales à
l'aune de ce qui pourrait se passer à
taïwan merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat qui était
passionnant voilà on a appris beaucoup
de choses grâce à vous merci laetitia
pour ce regard sur la
l'opinion publique de ces deux pays jeu